I can't believe I agreed to do this I'm
very hairy I have an extremely high pay
dollar some people do this all the time
right so I can't be that bad I'm pretty
sure I'll be okay for as prevalent as
bikini waxes seem to be I have very
little idea of what they actually are so
you're a first-time waxer I really kind
of don't know there's choices that you
have I kind of want to do what I do with
mine or we're just like to walk in I'm
like hey just clean me up I get shapes
you can get shapes I get a dragon oh no
come on in and then we'll get started
no time for regrets I'm here I'm more
naked than I'm used to being in public
places I'm sure it's gonna be fine this
is the most nervous I've been about
anything in a very long time I'm sorry
to get so well acquainted with my I
still just have this like fear of my
skin coming up get going oh that's warm
who is the first person to do this first
piece okay do it to it yeah that wasn't
bad at all okay oh cool it's a one-two
punch okay of hot torture and then
pulling torture oh it's like a short
tiny electric shock don't cross your
legs on me you don't want to get stuck
together oh cool
oh that one hurt all right lift your
lace we're gonna do your button after
like I do like a baby this is going to
be an interesting area yeah oh do it hmm
okay for this and I just have you take a
deep breath what's so bad now I'm just
sad all the girls that the buzz would be
the easiest was way worse you guys are a
little bit more sensitive in this area
yeah for sure
you're telling me you know they say
beauty is pain now hearing somebody say
I'm going to get waxed I know that it's
the equip
hearing somebody say like I'm gonna go
jump out of a one-story building
I feel poetic right now - I'm gonna have
a spring of my stuff like I'm gonna go
just waltz in them great
it's a giant big significant thing that
people do and a lot of people don't
appreciate them enough for doing it
no well hopefully now you'll appreciate
every woman who tells you oh I gotta go
get waxed I know
and then hopefully you'll be like yo me
too let's go together
you do it I do it I'm still not sure how
I feel about it I feel like I could run
faster it's just so comfortable it's
like an unfurnished basement
I recommend that all guys try this if
not to look sexier but to understand
what women have to go through it's like
take doing the regulator cap off a car
you know everything is just much freer
and looser